(Buques cargados con grandes tesoros, aventureros
surcando los siete mares, banderas negras
con calaveras y huesos cruzados, feroces corsarios
con parches en el ojo y patas de palo.
Leyendas que ponen los pelos de punta, como
las de Barbanegra, Francis Drake o Henry Morgan.
Piratas, filibusteros, bucaneros, corsarios
que durante siglos han surcado los mares en
busca de oro, plata y piedras preciosas.)
Decidme, ¿quién no ha crecido con historias
de feroces, intrépidos y osados piratas?
Con las leyendas de Barbanegra, novelas como
la isla del tesoro o personajes como el capitán
Jack Sparrow.
A lo largo de la historia de la humanidad
los piratas han causado fascinación, admiración
o terror. Pero no penséis ni por un momento
que han desaparecido.
Las guerras ya no se libran únicamente por
tierra, mar y aire. Ahora, en nuestros días
cada vez más, lo hacen también por el ciberespacio.
Sí, a ver, no creo que esto sea algo que
os sorprenda a ninguno de vosotros.
Un país puede causar un enorme daño a otro
país simplemente atacando sus sistemas informáticos:
Imaginaos todo lo que se puede hacer: bloquear
sistemas de comunicación, transporte, equipos
eléctricos, los sistemas financieros y practicamente
cualquier cosa, porque hoy ya casi todo funciona
con ordenadores.
Esto es algo que todas las potencias y prácticamente
todos los países del mundo lo saben. Incluido,
amigos, Corea del Norte.
Sí, sí, habéis escuchado bien.
Un momento, ¿no os lo creéis? Pues amigos
no deberías ser tan incrédulos.
Veréis, durante los últimos años, el país
más cerrado, más hermético del planeta
no solo ha desarrollado un arsenal de armas
nucleares también se ha montado su propio
equipo de hackers.
(En 1998, Kim Jong-il, el anterior líder
de Corea del Norte y padre del actual líder,
Kim Jong-un, estableció la que se conoce
como Unidad 121, un cuerpo de guerra cibernética
que según se cree está formado por miles
de personas que trabajan mañana, tarde y
noche preparándose para sembrar el caos con
ataques cibernéticos contra redes de comunicaciones,
energía y todo tipo de infraestructuras estratégicas
de los adversarios del régimen de Pyongyang.)
Si, se que puede parecer algo muy extraño
y toda una paradoja que uno de los regímenes
más herméticos y pobres del mundo, en un
país donde el acceso a internet está muy
pero que muy restringido y donde incluso el
gobierno ha desarrollado su “propio internet”
- una especie de intranet super cutre y vigilada
- cuente con uno de los ejércitos de hackers
más peligrosos de la red.
(“Para ellos, el arma más poderosa es cibernética.
En Corea del Norte, se le conoce como la Guerra
Secreta. Los incentivos para los ciberexpertos
de Corea del Norte son muy fuertes, son gente
rica en Pyongyang. - Jang Se Yul, antiguo
estudiante de la escuela militar de ciencias
de la computación de Corea del Norte)
Amigos, la persona que hizo estas declaraciones
a Reuters, Jang Se Yul, es un joven norcoreano
que antes de huir a Corea del Sur estudió
codo con codo con jóvenes que hoy integran
la Unidad 121.
Su testimonio corrobora lo que muchos expertos
llevan defendiendo años: para el régimen
norcoreano sus unidades de guerra cibernética
son toda una prioridad.
De hecho, la Unidad 121 depende de la Dirección
General de Reconocimientos, una agencia de
inteligencia que informa y responde directamente
ante el mismísimo Kim Jong-un.
Y no solo eso, según algunas estimaciones,
estos equipos de ataque cibernéticos compuestos
por casi 2.000 hackers podrían estar acaparando
entre el 10 y el 20% de todo el presupuesto
militar norcoreano.
[Creo que esto ya nos da una idea muy clara
de la enorme importancia que tienen para el régimen]
Pues bien, según se cree su primer ataque
a gran escala se produjo en el año 2013.
Veréis, haciendo uso de un malware conocido
como DarkSeoul, estos equipos de hackers consiguieron
borrar una enorme cantidad de datos y congelar
o apagar alrededor de 32.000 equipos en Corea
del Sur, equipos entre los que se encontraban
los servidores de 4 grandes bancos y 3 agencias
de televisión surcoreanas.
Y ojo porque todo esto no es ninguna broma.
(Apenas un año más tarde, en 2014 la Corporación
de Energía Nuclear de Corea del Sur anunció
que sus sistemas informáticos habían sido
hackeados. Los hackers norcoreanos habían
robado planos de sus reactores nucleares,
información personal sobre sus más de 10.000
empleados y otra información no revelada.)
Desde entonces los ataques que los hackers
norcoreanos han llevado a lo largo y ancho
del mundo han sido continuos, convirtiéndose
en todo un quebradero de cabeza, una pesadilla
para muchas empresas y gobiernos.
Por ejemplo, en el año 2017 estos mismos tipos al
servicio de Kim Jong-Un, lanzaron el vírus,
WannaCry que se convirtió en el mayor ataque
con software maligno de toda la historia.
Se estima que afectó a más de 300.000 equipos
y que puso contra las cuerdas a multinacionales
de la talla de Fedex o Telefónica.
(Los gobiernos de Estados Unidos y Reino Unido
han dicho que Corea del Norte fue responsable
del ataque de malware WannaCry que afectó
a hospitales, negocios y bancos en todo el mundo)
Un detalle importante. Estos hackers no solo
operan desde Corea del Norte. Una vez que
han sido formados muchos de estos hackers
se envían a China, al sudeste asiático o
a otros países con identidades falsas para
que puedan actuar desde allí.
¿Sorprendidos? Pues esperad un momento porque
Corea del Norte tiene otra unidad de ciberguerra
que creo os va a llamar aún más la atención.
(UNIDAD 180: ASALTO AL TESORO)
Vale, Corea del Norte no se ha llevado nunca
precisamente bien con la comunidad internacional.
Sin embargo, desde que Kim Jong-un llegó
al poder en 2011 y aceleró el programa nuclear
norcoreano las sanciones contra se han multiplicado.
Y, amigos, desarrollar un programa nuclear
y balístico no es algo que resulte precisamente
barato. Así que la pregunta es… si las
sanciones internacionales te cortan el grifo
y te impiden comerciar con el resto del mundo…
entonces,
¿Qué diantres puedes hacer para obtener
las divisas que necesitas para seguir comprando
en el mercado negro todo lo que requieres
para completar tu programa nuclear? ¿Alguna idea?
Amigos, esta es la pregunta que Kim Jong-Un
se hizo muy pronto… y sabéis qué.. en
su caso su respuesta fue La Unidad 180.
(En 2013, cuando Kim Jong-un empezaba a sentir
la presión de las sanciones internacionales
decidió establecer la conocida como Unidad
180 con 500 profesionales de la Unidad 121.
¿Con qué objetivo? Hackear la mayor cantidad
posible de cuentas bancarias y de criptodivisas
para obtener recursos con los que financiar
su programa nuclear y balístico)
Sí, sí. Habéis escuchado bien. En 2013
Corea del Norte montó su propia unidad de
atracadores cibernéticos. Un enorme equipo
dedicado a robar dinero para pagar los caprichos
del líder.
(“El principal trabajo de la unidad 180
es obtener divisas extranjeras para financiar
proyectos para desarrollar cinco grandes armas
- incluyendo bombas nucleares, misiles de
largo alcance y misiles balísticos para ser
lanzados desde submarinos. Kim Heung-kwang,
antiguo profesor de ciencias de la computación
en una universidad norcoreana)
Pues bien, desde que fue montada, esta Unidad
180 ha llevado a cabo numerosos robos, decenas
y decenas de robos, contra bancos y entidades
de intercambio de criptodivisas de todo el
mundo.
[Bueno, en 2016, incluso, le robaron algo
más de 100, 100 millones de dólares al Banco
Central de Bangladesh]
(“La desesperación del gobierno norcoreano
por el efectivo está impulsando el aumento
de los ataques cibernéticos contra bancos
y otras empresas de los Estados Unidos y del
resto del mundo”. Un funcionario de EEUU
en declaraciones a la CNN)
(Los norcoreanos se han convertido rápidamente
en los más avanzados y persistentes ladrones
digitales de bancos. [...] Está claro que
las sanciones económicas internacionales
están funcionando y han obligando a los norcoreanos
a recurrir a enfoques alternativos para conseguir
ingresos. Anthony Ferrante, ex funcionario
de ciberseguridad del FBI y de la Casa Blanca.)
Grupos tan conocidos en la red como Lazarus
o Reaper dependen de esta Unidad 180, y por
tanto del gobierno norcoreano.
[Sí, la verdad que Corea del Norte se ha
tomado en serio eso de convertirse en el malo
malísimo de la política internacional: armas
nucleares, hackers, secuestros, tráfico de
armas… no importa, si es ilegal y es considerado
malo… Kim Jong- Un se encarga.]
Ahora bien, la gran pregunta: realmente, ¿Cuánto
dinero han podido robar estos hackers norcoreanos
en los últimos años?
(Pues no es algo fácil de determinar pero
un Panel de expertos que informa al Consejo
de Seguridad de Naciones Unidas ha estimado
que durante los últimos años, especialmente
desde el 2016, Pyongyang ha acumulado alrededor
de 670 millones de dólares en moneda extranjera
y criptodivisas.)
Casi 700 millones de dólares [que se sepa]
robados por la Unidad 180 a bancos y a intermediarios
de criptodivisas. Luego utilizan blockchain
para cubrir sus huellas y transferir todo
este dinero a donde lo necesitan, por ejemplo
para pagar a sus proveedores de equipos tecnológicos
en el mercado negro.
Ya lo véis. Según parece el gobierno de
Corea del Norte está pagando buena parte
de su programa nuclear con criptodivisas…
que evidentemente son más difíciles de rastrear
y no dependen de la regulación internacional.
Pero aquí no terminan todas las actividades
de la Unidad 180 para conseguir pasta.
Como han cojido experiencia, ademas de trincar,
la Unidad 180 también desarrolla software
para empresas internacionales, especialmente
de Japón y China.
[Oye ya que estamos y tenemos a todos estos
hackers pues… habrá que aprovechar, ¿no?]
Pues bien, estos curiosos pedidos son coordinados
por algunos de los grupos pro-Corea del Norte
que hay por el mundo.
Por supuesto esta Unidad 180 ofrece unas tarifas
por los suelos….y en muchos casos las empresas
contratantes ni siquiera saben que están
haciendo negocios con la inteligencia norcoreana.
Y eso, amigo, implica un riesgo muy alto,
¿por qué?
Pues porque según parece en estos programas
suelen venir repletos de puertas traseras
que llegado el momento le podrían permitir
a la inteligencia norcoreana controlar los
dispositivos donde se instala este software
ya sea para bloquearlos o para seguir trincando
pasta.
[No me digáis que estos tipos del régimen
norcoreano no son todo unos bandidos].
(“Las compañías de software que la Unidad
180 ha establecido en países como Vietnam
o Malasia están ocultas como compañías
normales. Y han suministrado sistemas de control
de fábricas y otros productos a empresas
japonesas”. Fumiaki Yamasaki, experto en
seguridad de la información”)
En fin, amigos, esta es la historia de cómo
Corea del Norte se las ha ingeniado para desarrollar
poderosos equipos de ciberguerra y conseguir
cientos de millones de dólares con los que
saltarse las sanciones internacionales y sacar
adelante su programa nuclear.
Los tiempos han cambiado y tal vez ya no hablemos
de surcar los mares o de piratas con parche
en el ojo, pero aquí estamos hablando básicamente
de piratería, y al fin y al cabo la red es
algo así como una especie de gran oceano.
Por cierto, ¿Os habéis preguntado alguna
vez de dónde diantres viene lo de los piratas
y el parche en el ojo? ¿Es que a todos los
piratas normalmente les faltaba un ojo?
Pues no, nada de eso.
Según parece, el parche tenía una función
muy, pero que útil: adaptarse mejor a los
cambios bruscos de luz. Por ejemplo, cuando
abordaban otro barco y entraban en su bodega.
Sí, veréis, el ojo humano tarda un montón
en acostumbrarse a la oscuridad… y ese es
un tiempo que no se tiene en un abordaje.
Así que los piratas se tapaban un ojo para
que este se adaptará muy rápido a la oscuridad.
Es decir, cuando entraban en un espacio más
oscuro rápidamente se cambiaban el parche
de lado y wuala, veían estupendamente.
Eso es lo que parece, y ojo que no es ninguna
tontería, es algo que se utiliza en los mismísimos
entrenamientos de la NASA.
En fin amigos, espero que este vídeo os haya
resultado interesante. Cómo siempre si ha
sido así echanos una mano dándole a like
y compartiendolo con tus amigos.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.